what's up taste buddies i am on the road
and in two days just two days from now
on wednesday july 20th i will be in
portland for the first time solo at the
arlene schnitzer concert hall seattle
the next day july 21st at the paramount
uh and for the first time in canada in
vancouver at the vogue theater july 22nd
tickets are all on sale they're coming
up in a few days hope to see you guys
there
fear not if you didn't hear your city
these just went on sale for the fall
they're all on sale right now hamilton
ontario toronto richmond virginia
hershey pennsylvania knoxville tennessee
atlanta georgia birmingham alabama
louisville kentucky evansville indiana
jacksonville tampa and orlando florida
sacramento san jose and santa rosa
california
if you didn't hear your city i'm going
to be adding more for the new year but
i'm grinding out there guys i'm
listening to you guys online when you
tell me come here come there i'm taking
into consideration so if you know
someone from those areas let them know
i'm coming through everything's on sale
right now savvolcanocomedy.com thanks
guys folks joe derose here from the
taste buds podcast hi taste buddies i
got dates coming up all over the place i
will be in atlantic city in august in
september i'll be in san diego
uh then i'm going to be in north
carolina i'm going to be in vegas i'm
going to be all over so just go to
jodarossainfo.com for all ticket links
and tour and show information also
please as always check out joey rose's
in new york city on the lower east side
bar and sandwich shop and social club
we're running six days a week opening at
12 p.m every day go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for
to the mic details about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only once hey
taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds and we got a special
collabo
today
the first of two collabos but don't
worry it's not a two-parter cause i know
how upset you all get when we god forbid
split an episode in two we're just doing
two episodes in a row two different
battles with the greats
are you garbage in the house today the
boys thank you thanks for having me
foley right it's fully that that's how
you go by in like age foley yeah
yeah so you say h foley every time
someone like when you when you say no
when i introduce myself yeah no i'm not
an actor no no no no no no i know i know
how you introduce you i mean like on
like when you guys are talking uh he's
fully my mom calls him foley like he's
right so who who says you excuse me age
foley nobody no nobody oh okay okay
so you just throw agent as to give a
little shout out to the first name yeah
it's a little how you do yeah you know
but it's not you don't so you don't just
say hey foley i say hi i'm henry if i
introduce myself to somebody i would say
but if i'm introducing you to our fans
right now i am
what role the h plays in that uh what do
you mean why do i use h foley yeah like
so now they know because when they're
looking at your name is h foley and he
goes by foley your name is savolcano you
go by cell that's real but his name is
henry but he goes by h my name but he
doesn't go by h stylized his first name
is h
what do you want to make there like
madonna just
coming to the stage
get it but that's like saying your name
is jay derosa it's but but but just
i see what you're saying you're saying
it's weird that you've made a choice on
the h and then disregard you drop the h
i'm intrigued sure i can clean this up
okay so i use h foley as like my stage
his real name's frank it's an alias he
owns money
by the way the fact that you don't go by
hank is batshit to me if my name was
henry i'd i'd be hank all day
people call me hank in my personal life
but i use things fully because my
personal life like there's a big
separation between church and studies
after you get whisked away from it
it's all the glitz and the glam i told
the limo driver please call me hank
no uh i'm named after my grandfather
when i was a little kid i had one of
those wooden plaques hanging over my car
yeah making like wood shop that my
cousin made from my grandfather and i
used to look at it i was very close with
him he passed away and you know i i said
if i ever start doing entertainment i
want to go by age foley okay
so i was actually
searching for something that you had a
reason yeah yeah yeah absolutely if you
didn't want to bring that up i
wholeheartedly apologize all of a sudden
i felt a little bit like barbara walters
i'll get naked right now
i had the old plaque and my name was is
sal but it wasn't like that old english
sure you know like that like it's like
wait it's way too much going on
yeah yeah yeah it was a little too busy
i don't know the kids still do that the
kids still have wood shop and [ __ ] like
that or no oh i didn't make that i
probably got it like
i've been in certain states yeah yeah
you know middle of the country i'm sure
there's still a skill yeah you know we
didn't have it in my high school because
i went to catholic school we didn't have
any of that real stuff
yeah i really missed out i didn't get
home act i didn't get any of that
questions
[Laughter]
i got a rat final coming up i would have
excelled at that stuff
yeah but it was weird because like it
classes an hour periods an hour long by
the time you get there you go oh you
only have like five minutes with the
machine you're waiting in
line yeah and they're from like the 60s
you're not using top-of-the-line
equipment my buddy my buddy lost his
finger in it right right off clean off
immediate extra high school kid yeah
yeah or junior high he was in junior
high did you get it
no it was off and it was off and a kid
it was on the ground and i swear to god
a kid picked it up and put it on the end
of his pencil and was like
messing around with it
shout out to stubbs
in high school not get shot down shut
down
yeah so it was like late 90s or whatever
that was a different time back then wow
the lawsuit alone you would assume now
yeah but i don't think anything happens
then it was just shake it off i don't
ever mention anything a couple of free
school lunches yeah that is free pizza
he got suspended
that is crazy that's horrific
because now i'm glad i didn't have that
stuff yeah my dad went to a vocational
high school and he it was a technical
high school he did would shop i got to
tell you this conversation
has awakened in me
a dream
to go back to a vocational school i
think i kind of want to those kids
always become a woodworker isn't that
just joining the union
i think if i was woodworking all day i
know i think people nowadays people are
buying groupons to do that stuff my wife
did that my wife went and like made like
a cigar box or something
i'm single they probably got a singles
meetup woodworking group i could go to
yeah i'm telling you what used to be
forced upon us is now our like we're
searching for a copy now yeah that's
nice that's nice get back to your roots
you know he's trying to pick up chicks
making license plates
yeah honey i like your two by fours i
was terrible at that stuff man kids
would make like these beautiful things
i was an idiot would you make
uh we had to do um do you have anything
that you made still i have one little
thing that i made from my mom it just
says mom's kitchen it was spelled it was
like a shrinky dink remember shrinky
dinks oh my god very similar to that but
i remember we had to do uh we had to
make a house
like a styrofoam like it was like an
architectural shower oh sure sure like a
model coming in with these beautiful
homes dude mine look like katrina
it's brutal you should have said that
you'd be like
this is post
you couldn't look more like a guy that
would know exactly what he was doing oh
yeah you should look like you would have
a little pencil behind your ear at all
with a knife you have your look is two
jobs and two jobs only okay
some kind of foreman construction
something yeah or morning radio in
florida yeah that's it those are the two
looks good vibes
i think i can pull off defensive line
coaches
absolutely i give you a coach and it's
in a semi-professional role
you look beyond kids yeah shout out to
the spartans yeah i'm trying to give
some kid a second chance
then he screws me when he signs with the
big agency yeah yeah i start drinking
again i had you over my house
you had nowhere to go on thanksgiving
and you threw me like this my wife
leaves me yeah you talk to me
no all right
and i start drinking in the fantasy are
you married no oh okay you just said my
wife's whole life's a lie his name is
stick with this yeah we're riffing here
my car died this morning and i'm just
breathing i'm a little scrambled in the
head right now you shouldn't be are you
going through the car
[Music]
oh no i'm just i'm just shot in the head
i bought this jeep it's been nothing but
problems and it's finally that's it i'm
selling it what you're getting it i'm
getting this last problem fixed and
selling it 2012.
but uh but anyway i don't want to talk
about day he bought it
it died the day he bought it then this
homeless person broke in and slept in it
then it got
at the time and sal likes to make fun of
the less fortunate he thinks it's funny
we are having a good time
a man that had to buy a used car because
that's what his budget allowed what do
you mean my car is 11 years old i'm
kidding
now who's being literal i'm joking the
second i say three words after he says
it it turns on me and now oh now i'm
dead that's how it works it's hot potato
baby
no
sal is right sounds very right it has
been headaches and there's no reason for
it there's no reason for it how he tried
to make up how long ago did you get a
car
i love this man so much i i was born
under a bad sign i this is this is this
is how that means the bqe
my luck i'm a truly lucky person in the
sense that i have fantastic luck or the
worst luck
when he was born complaining was in
retrograde yeah yeah
[Music]
my luck will be
my luck will be literally not a leo he's
a curmudgeon
here's my luck he's not a leo he's
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm a fourteenth man myself that's why
that's the only one i know yeah it's
coming up too yeah what are the traits
of a leo do you share any leadership
really straightening the check
[Music]
asking for more bread
anger
honestly it is
yeah not good not good at listening to
people but wait anger is part of leo
not anger but like stubbornness like
yeah yeah yeah let me let me
let me sum up my luck in this car in and
of itself this is my luck this is
exactly my luck
i buy the car right i got it for during
the lockdown i got it for 10 grand out
the door okay that's a real dirtbag line
so 10 grand out the door
out the door right which for jeep
wrangler is a good was a good deal
i got it 10 grand okay the day after i
bought it i got a surprise grant from
the sba
for ten thousand dollars so my luck is
great in that like i bought a car and
then i was i got the money for free
immediately free car
but then the car is nothing but problems
for the entire two years
that's my luck in a [ __ ] nutshell it
is fantastic versus utterly horrific
it's never just up the middle i said it
it is it's seinfeld it's the seinfeld
where he's like i'm not breaking leaving
him yeah i'm even steven yeah i say this
up was down
it serves you right for buying a jeep
wrangler what are you a lifeguard what
are you doing
with the surfboard waves of the people
when you drive by them i had a lot of i
had a lot of tank tops that were going
to waste
what am i going to do with all these
oakleys
i got to get it
fantasized about having a jeep but i'm
just it just never happened it's not
practical you wait do you wave to people
when you drive by i wave oh what did you
buy did you buy it in the winter i
cranked sugar ray
[Laughter]
i just wonder
i'm getting rid of this [ __ ] thing
i'm going right into a hyundai or a nice
reliable height
hyundai santa fe hybrid baby i narrowed
it down that's what i'm getting
wait you already know about it yeah oh
yeah i i've been dying
the warranties because i heard i knew
that has a real nice one i knew this
[ __ ] day was coming
drinking his smoothie what the with the
strawberry on it
palm beach
yeah i knew this day was coming i've
been looking at cars
that's good that's great just this day
especially in new york you don't use it
all the time you have it's like you set
it and forget it yeah jersey to lease it
too i'm not even dealing with the [ __ ] i
got a guy i'll take care of you does he
deal in new yeah because you got a full
time you think southbound counter with
the car guys
because you got a full load cause you
got a full life he's a broker baby get
anything you want
a broker he's not how am i test driving
if he doesn't have me actually
test drive it at the place then he goes
and finds it and there are full lots out
here because in manhattan there are no
lots no go to a place that has the car
test drive it especially in jersey
staten island no problem i've never seen
somebody so weary of a favor happening
what's this guy going to do his
profession is he's a
broker for leases and finance cars so if
you haven't heard of this profession i
only i only realized it fully about
three four years ago okay and i've since
turned him on to everyone i know okay so
i was looking for my car and i the least
i have and i um
i went to i was looking at four or five
different cars and i narrowed it down to
the car i wanted i went to three
dealerships including the one i've been
going through for a decade and they said
they gave me the best price and the
other guys said they gave me the best
president anyway one call to this guy he
texted me back in 15 minutes i had just
met him he was referral from another
friend
his price that he gave to me in 15
minutes via a text was two thousand
dollars cheaper than the third
dealership i went to that told me that
they would be in the other way the best
they can do
then he asked me what day i wanted it
and then he drove it to my home handed
me the keys and drove away that's great
get me in bed with this guy you want
that
you wanna you wanna be in bed with the
guy
what am i supposed to do that i thought
you were in the car you're hurtful today
you're a little hurtful today oh my lord
who are you gonna pawn the jeep on
that's what i wanna know what poor
bastard is good
for the jeep that's good
this is great publicity for the dilemma
you're trying to sell to the public the
car stings if somebody's i'll take nine
grand
if somebody tries to sell you a pink
wrangler don't make the move
i can picture you being like look it's a
wrangler 11 grand out the door
i mean i got an sba loan what's the deal
i mean it's crazy well listen is there
something too i don't know i mean you
know you're a man of some notoriety you
know like is there a thing to having joe
derosa's car like john
everyone's talking about i'm sure
somebody out there would be surprised
you didn't get a free one to be honest i
don't hear a word they're saying
a free one what do you mean i don't know
a free one right from the dealership a
free car yeah what are you doing
what are you talking about awesome but
he doesn't know how anything works like
dude somebody will come to this he's
like you're driving yourself around
sometimes they come to dessert you think
i'm getting a vehicle yeah you should
what do you thought you shouldn't pay
for a car or a slice of pizza in this
town
you want to follow me around this is the
cloud sal is carrying we all went to
dinner
by the way and i'll clump andrew santino
into this too we all went out to dinner
in brooklyn santino a man carrying a
little bit of notoriety himself now the
most famous guy any of us know new
yorkers new yorker i would argue we went
out to dinner in brooklyn we ordered
coffee and did a dinner kid comes over
he goes listen
we're closing in five minutes we don't
really feel like making the coffee
i mean there's people that'll open the
restaurant for them
okay [ __ ] go make a cup of tea at
home he put it on us though he made
guilty the guy was like so if you want
something
he goes we clean down the machine that's
wild but if you want it we'll make it
for you it's like so crazy
a great place i've been there it's been
there forever a great
great place yeah yeah and they were nice
then they comp to dessert they
did they yeah oh okay okay that's that's
good yeah good dessert we don't
necessarily got the pie with no coffee
you're sitting like an [ __ ] eating
dessert no we got regatta cheesecake and
we could we couldn't have black coffee
[ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah i don't know what do i do do i
get any perks like that
i don't really know
people comp stuff and i get it i'll get
in a lot like lines or events or stuff
like that you've taken me to staff where
you've been like oh i know you know emma
remember that thing in
[Music]
shrimp
what was the place we got the free crab
legs the white house
[Laughter]
they did it as a joke on master of none
when aziz goes backstage at radio city
musical busta rhymes goes you ever have
the shrimp back there they did it as a
joke the shrimp were unfucking they were
really good yeah that was that was only
one thing though you really focused on
i'm using it as an ex no no it was one
of the things it was nice there's this
old uh room upstairs where the lady the
owner used to live there and it's
probably it's probably haunted but it's
a real like old space like with like
it's like kind of like a 30-foot ceiling
and everything is gold like it's like
it's weird like it's right
on it i don't care what's in there keeps
the shrimp i'm out
when you go up to this lounge they're so
used to doing like this concierge sort
of service for you
they give you a tour and they go like
this is the elevator that thomas
jefferson uses when he spoke here
whatever the [ __ ] right and you're like
hey lady get to the shrimp
where are those prawns
i was super late so sound everybody's
upstairs it's open bar i'm just trying
to get the [ __ ] up there and get free
drinks
and the lady goes okay so i'm going to
give you the tour and i go
it's fine
breaks their ankle here's here's where
they shoot them
here's where they put them down
you throw them in the alley right here
that's so funny this is the rocket
graveyard to your left
i know i met a rockette once i mean like
an old lady who was a rockette that
would be the one i want to meet yeah i
want to meet that one whether it has
some stories been around i believe her
name was elaine and she was an older
lady but she had like she could tell she
was like a hippie chick sure she was
born and bred like here and she she had
like uh purple hair even as an old lady
that's fun yeah not blue hair like a per
like yeah like purple yeah
yeah you still need a kick
i never asked him because i probably
should have yeah she showed her photos
and stuff though i had a lot of good
stories i met a lady in the same bar
that used to
uh date uh like in the public she was
a supermodel
in the 50s and the 60s in the 60s and
70s i mean front page international
supermodel that dated andy warhol whoa
and then she ended up living here she
lived in a lot of different places and
uh she would be a regular patron of the
bar but she was
wild that's zany like out there like
kooky like you know she was like she was
really really really cool she was
eccentric yeah think about what she did
she hung out
with him where they used to have lost
and do drugs and like sure she just
throw [ __ ] at the wall you know right
she recently passed folks let's talk
about better help what a great
great sponsor uh that we have here on
this podcast
uh i like to try to take care of my mind
in the best way possible
and i think that it's something
important for all of us to do and that's
why i love better help online therapy
what i really appreciate about it is
that it has sort of made a convenience
out of getting the help and the mental
health rather more specifically that we
all need from time to time uh i've been
somebody who has gone to therapy
throughout my life and i think that the
experience of trying to get the therapy
itself is often so hard so daunting so
problematic that you don't end up
getting to the thing you need which is
the therapy itself and betterhelp makes
that super easy it kind of eliminates
all of the bs and lets you just get in
there to get what you need they're
offering online therapy
through video through phone even live
chat therapy sessions you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you can just talk which is great it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched to a
therapist in under 48 hours that says it
all it's easy and they're helping you
get what you need our listeners get 10
off the first month at betterhelp.com
taste buds so visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds
folks it's summertime and cooking and
all that stuff ain't always easy but
let's talk about factor they're making
it easy for you to eat well for
breakfast lunch dinner and everything in
between with fresh never frozen meals
that are delicious
[Applause]
you won't believe they're actually
nutritious that's how good they are you
can feel great all summer long with
calorie smart meals they got keto
options if you want them expertly
portioned and they're going to keep you
on track towards your goals factor is
now offering 32 meals per week including
as i said 11 keto options plus a lot of
seasonal add-ons so there's no need to
eat the same thing every day every night
sometimes when you try to eat right you
start you get stuck in a rut and then
you start to hate eating because it's
the same thing all the time
factors flexible they're going to help
you get around that also if you're
moving around this summer maybe going on
vacation they can help you get your
stuff wherever you're going okay and you
can change your orders as you go so you
can change your your your week me meal
plans from four to 18 meals per week
whatever you want
factor equals free time instead of
spending those precious after work hours
hustling around the store and in the
kitchen look they're gonna deliver the
ready-made meals right to your door so
get these things trust me vegan options
veggie options keto options calorie
smart options press
cold pressed juices smoothies energy
bites extra protein veggie sides more
and more and more everything you need to
keep you fueled head to
go.factor75.com
tastebuds120 and use code tastebuds120
to get 120 off that's code tastebuds120
at geo.gov
tastebuds120 for 120 off
my buddy's wife jeannie
had to leave their honeymoon their
honeymoon was in rome and in paris she
had to leave the honeymoon a week early
because she got a job with rockettes oh
no way and it's such like a sought after
job she had to leave the honeymoon and
start the training there's no other
kicking conglomerate
that's right if you're in the business
of kicking you've got to be a rocket
cashed in my buddy called me he's like
bro can you get on a plane i got a free
ride for you in rome for a week if you
can get over here because my wife's got
to leave the honeymoon so i went to rome
and we [ __ ] partied all the way are
you serious yeah so you benefited from
the
i did establishment
honeymoon with my buddy imagine being a
young gal that kicks
like the moon
and you can't get in that's time she's
just walking around life doing [ __ ]
high kicks and there's no place for her
you know that's tough that reminds me
there's a
right and then what are those people
left doing there's one kicking around
look it only pays
i mean 1500 a week's not a bad gig but
the problem is it's such a short period
of time it says they only make about 36
brand new year that's yeah i mean new
york that's nothing so that i remember
her saying that was one of the issues
with it was like it was such a it was
such a
uh um
a privilege to be a part of it
but you have to
cut out this one section of the year for
it and then the rest of the year you're
like wait what job is going to let
unless you're waitressing or something
sure you could do something you could do
a field goal
for three months
that's the privilege to be a part of it
pay them what they deserve yeah that's
wild come on 39 grand
they're giving away jumbo shrimp
isn't there like a hundred rockettes how
many others it's a lot right there's
like two walls of
lot that's a that's a them
one that's all they can afford it i'm
sure they can afford it i'm just saying
so 80 times 40 that's like 2.4 mil i
don't know if that math is around i
don't know justin justin kicks alone oh
right 80 times 40 40 000 a year eight
zero
no that's three point two
eight times four is the other three
three hundred and twenty five
dollars
no it's it's it's how much was it three
point two million forty thousand
times ten is four hundred thousand four
hundred thousand times eight is three
point two million yeah yeah three point
two million yeah
all right that's it that's that's a
hefty that's hefty yeah that's a lot but
i mean it's also like the tickets are
probably a hundred and eighty bucks a
collection or whatever so so they
and they could pay them in 10. yeah but
that's but that's camels costs a lot
though
you can't pay that i mean the
they have cameras
you've never gone to the christmas
spectacular no no oh
there's actual camels they do a whole
nativity scene and they just they card
out all the lives not for real i've seen
them in a park jesus yeah it's no joke
here what's a ticket pimp he's looking
up a ticket i think that's a fair salary
for eighty one dollars for it and that's
that's that's a pretty fair salary for
that limited amount of weight i mean how
much this is a year what the hell or a
season it's like it's like two four
months man like you know i think it's
like comedy i think you know the years
that they put into getting to that point
true and also and also what are they
what other jobs and opportunities are
they sacrificing when they have to
because what jobs you have where you're
like i need three months off i got to
kick the [ __ ] out of that i'm saying i
mean that's the problem but at the same
time it's like
what do you i don't know that's a tough
call i assume it's probably similar to
comedy in the sense of like
they're in some other dancing gig where
it's like hey i gotta go i'm leaving
this play to go do this or whatever and
they go oh of course you got called up
to the rockettes but it's also like
you're you're you're a chorus person
right
by the way have they inject have they
gender mixed the rockettes yet the
rockers
that's that's rockers
that's got to be kind of another way
rockets stay busy during the all seasons
by teaching fitness classes or taking
extra dance lessons to improve upon
their expertise who wrote that
and of course to stay in tip-top shape
to perform 16 shows a week that's a lot
whoa that's a hundred bucks a show it's
less than a hundred that's right it's
less than a hundred bucks six that's not
even feature works that's not good yeah
they probably can't touch this right now
oh yeah are you kidding me right i agree
insane i bet you the camel's making more
probably i'm telling the handler
i'm telling you whoever's handling that
camel you know who makes more than that
who i used to work i grew up near the
second biggest mall in the entire
country king of the pressure
plaza you know we're from the same area
the sand when the court was the court
the court as a dying is dying on the
vine now but the court remember used to
be the fancy part
when the court was the court
the santa claus at christmas was a huge
attraction there that santa claus when i
worked there
i would we would talk to him when he was
like like on his way over to work hey
how do you get a gig like this yeah and
he told us she goes what's the north
pole this is my whole year oh yeah he
goes dude my job is full-time as being
santa he goes dude i i he goes i live in
like the poconos or wherever the [ __ ] he
lived for
11 months out of the year and he goes
and then i fly in here no
what were you doing there what did you
do there i had so many jobs in that mall
over the year at that time i was working
at a uh
i was working at a cart
that was man like one of the kiosks
you weren't even in the store you were
in the in the house
i worked there i worked the stores but
dude
the cart cart was that was the that was
the game yeah maybe the
you didn't have to peruse you got to sit
there as people you can get a chair and
you were alone which means something
don't get hit
when you wanted to take a break you
locked that register and you walked the
[ __ ] off yeah why were you moving
i worked at i once i got i worked in
stores first
and then the thing that took me off for
this corporate lifestyle
the thing it's the thing that caught me
off stores i swear to god the thing
about my stories i worked at a rock
t-shirt shop and it was it was like
i thought it was gonna be like the best
store gig i could get in the mall i was
like how cool is that you were selling
rock t-shirts the lady was such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that ran it
i actually drew him she drove him to
carts yeah
i caught a kid stealing and chased the
kid through the mall and grabbed the kid
and and brought her back
and got like i liked that you know
whatever her in there that was a nice
twist got the merchandise and all that
back he's like so i grabbed a little
you put yourself [ __ ]
girl and i brought her back and and she
goes
she goes uh
the the story the policy that if you
caught somebody stealing you got a
reward for it and she only gave me half
because her like her dad or something
was behind the counter and she goes well
my dad was standing there so i want to
give him half and i go your dad didn't
do a [ __ ] thing i chased the kid
through the morning i got to jonas
brought his t-shirt back yeah what do
you guys split a t-shirt with your dad
on the weekends cool t-shirts it was
like it was like punk rock like dead
kennedy's and stuff right and then she
said i swear to god she said to one of
my managers she goes you know i'm tired
of these people coming in here and
trying to jew me down on my prices
oh my god
between the two things i was like i'm
done with the stores i'm done store life
sucks i went to the carts i never looked
back i worked
i pictured it i pictured joe at the cart
one day telling a bunch of girls this
story yeah you guys hear about the big
robbery last week
he's got an orange julius in his hands
i worked at a i worked at an ice cream
cart
which i learned quickly don't ever work
at a food cart because then you got to
go downstairs and restock so i got up to
food carts i worked at a cell phone
cover store backwards cell phones like
that was like a big thing man you are
all bozo yeah yeah
vibes dude first i was at the gravitron
no offense but cell phone case cart is
the lowest on the show it's always like
a kid who can't be bothered on their
phone it's like they're always trying to
sell you pure [ __ ] at a ten thousand
percent markup and call it a deal yeah
they act like they're working at
tiffany's this was back when when the
nokia was the leading phone cases for
that yeah you could pay down the market
was wide open
back in the good old days like a wild
west before government regulations
stepped in you could pay to have your
phone shell changed
so because i had that nokia yeah yeah
it was the 3100 yeah yeah yeah 3100 the
nokia 3100 yeah yep
snake on it yeah
3100 300 that was my first phone i like
how he's talking about it like it's a
test and you put it really
they would just sound like you could
download it because i didn't smoke on
the water but it just sounded like the
buck
it was like an eight bit like a nintendo
like
yeah jewelry cart worked in a jewelry
cart that sold like wu-tang but
how long did you work there would you
work a weekend at each place you asked
me a question i'm trying to get you guys
i worked there every summer through like
high school and college okay that's and
then but the best car the best car
you're going to travel europe this
summer
back into cards baby
best card i worked at because nobody
gave of [ __ ] or ever came up to it this
lady had a cart of babushkas oh man it
was just scarves
that was a dream
you were stationed
i just sat in the bush kids for a summer
in the summer dude i wrote i wrote like
that's when i started like when i first
started writing things and being
creative i wrote plays i just sat there
just writing and reading i love that
i love that i love that the reality was
if you walked by his cart
25 years ago at the king of prussia mall
you'd see a teen joe derosa sitting out
of a bush car
feverishly punching away
at a play punching i was
oh dude it was awesome what a [ __ ]
dream i didn't know how good i had it
dude i was just at a mall and somebody
had a cart
but it's so weird to see it now because
the malls are empty yeah so but the
people are still open in carts i'm like
get a store get right get your act
together a little bit you know what i
mean we need some confidence i always
wondered like you ever go to a cart and
no one's there no i refuse to shop
no one's there and you're like you might
want to get something right and you're
like you're looking around you go see if
they're talking to the person of the
other car oh yeah yeah yeah and then
after a while you're like should i just
take something but then
someone's watching someone's entrapment
and then after a while you just yeah joe
derosa comes right now
i got two free babushkas today
that's my collar right there
i waited an hour
but then you just kind of throw your
hands up i get i get like i'm like
what do you want me to do i'm trying to
give you some money give your money yeah
yeah that
was you we should do the battle by the
way
yeah
i'm gonna do something and it's i don't
want to make it about me but i have ocd
and i had to just put this point
in of course and then we'll be able to
you'd understand i've been looking at it
the whole entire time sure
i thought he was just making eyes with
me i didn't know
i didn't know i didn't know it was a
mental disorder
no i have it i'm with it yeah all right
i'm good now jordan i really apologize
no all good yeah sorry for that pillow i
have ocd and it's terrible that's the
only way i have it too and the points uh
which chant do you want to do today
friendly or not these guys have fun wait
no we're on the same team
[Laughter]
uh no matter what happens i love you so
that would come out the other end of it
okay okay or if we want to really get
heated we chant it's time to get salty
it's time to get salted okay so next
next next episode with these guys we'll
do the chant because we're we'll be
we'll be you'll see yeah yeah so we're
actually on the same team
we haven't done this before have we ever
been on the same team i don't think so
have we pimp
already
oh yes again sorry we're capturing so
what are we doing first
lunchables
versus
bagel bites
okay you guys ready yeah here we go
b-a-t-t-l-e
bus
here we go this is fun man these guys
have a good time
i love it
we are team lunchables your team bagel
bikes that's basically the battle of the
after school snacks that's right or the
or the quick fix on the go after school
do it yourself
kind of like childhood slash
adulthood
i'm not above getting a lunchables on a
drive you know that's when i'm stopping
on the road when i'm in a you know
7-eleven i need something to eat yeah
now what what as courtesy to you guys as
our guests professionals thank you
opening uh opening stick by the way
wawa's was just in pa they're
disappearing like [ __ ] they're
dropping wawa actually just hit me up
because we have something on our set i
love them and they hit me up and they
were like can we send you some stuff i
just got it it wasn't great i've shouted
out a little bit
yeah they sent me some right i asked if
i could wear their merch on the show
and we were in the middle of talks and
they sent me a thing of merch but i i
rock a it's a nice hoodie they gave it
it's a great hoodie the black one with
the white oh i got gray but it's really
good if you can wear it
yeah really yeah i have to ask any
anything that's any image of anything
especially a logo i had to get
permission really and if not they'll get
to blur me out so a lot of times that's
why i gotta get you a lot of times i'll
wear my friend's merch that's what i
started
oh that's the one and i make my own
t-shirts i had to find solves for these
things i thought it was because the
network didn't want to give away free
advertising to whatever product it was
no i think it's more so that you're like
yeah you can't just you're a guest
associate licensed
over themselves you're wearing their
merch well you never know what's gonna
happen you know like that's right i'm
wearing their shirt and then all of a
sudden i do something that's you know
um
you guys as guests can have opening
argument as to why you think bagel bites
are superior to the lunchables well i
want to say this you know we're focusing
on the after-school snack aspect the kid
that actually brought now listen i love
the marketing i love the idea of
lunchables i'm not saying they're not
good but the kid they're showed up right
the kid that showed up to school with
the lunchable that was a bad look he was
a dirtball yeah what he smelled weird
what his clothes what you believe that
that was that was happening on earth i
didn't have that experience i envied a
lunchable kid now
that cheese has a little snack in there
they got the whole cafeteria yeah this
that they think
i went to catholic school they don't
feed the kids like that wait hold on a
second no you gotta wait and then pay
for your food as well until fourth grade
we had a we had a cafeteria that would
blow your socks but you really had a
lunch
where
for some reason there was an event going
on in the caf
hold on a second hold on
but we're getting sidetracked we're
getting
[Laughter]
cafeteria that's where we had the stage
and the events it was also doubled as a
basketball court you got to understand
yeah that's what it was yep
folks let's talk about upside okay uh
here's the thing
you can
cringe
at the price of almost anything anywhere
these days whether it's pumping your gas
and you're seeing that price or you're
getting the bill the bill after you eat
the meal or maybe you're just trying to
buy some stuff you like to buy whether
it's clothing or whatever and you're
noticing that suddenly your favorite
go-to pair of sneakers or pants or
whatever is way up there in price
it's inflation it sucks it's happening
there's nothing we can do about it but
upside is here to help you you can start
by downloading their app and it's for
anyone who's looking to buy things in
their regular life okay so it's
inflation inflation it's happening and
it sucks but that's why upside can help
upset is an incredible app for anyone
who's buying gas or groceries or dining
out with every purchase you're getting
cash back download the upside app from
the google store uh or the apps you know
the apple app store whatever and use
promo code taste buds and get five
dollars off or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
okay
you just this is a great offer this is a
great offer cash back on stuff you're
already buying anyway so you can claim
an offer for whatever you're buying on
upside check in at the business okay you
pay as usual with your credit card or
debit card and then you get paid you get
money back in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs upside can
earn you three times more the cash back
uh and you can cash out at any time to
your bank account to your paypal to your
e-gift card for amazon or whatever and
other brands this is a great thing
upside
users are earning more than a million
dollars every week that's total that's
not
i'm not ordering i'm not earning a
million you know what i'm saying anyway
they're getting a lot of people a lot of
cash back uh on their purchases and it's
great so download the free upside app
and use promo code taste buds to get
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
that's five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more using promo code taste buds what's
up to our sponsor credit karma folks hey
do you want a new credit card but you're
not sure how to choose one uh here's the
thing you're getting these offers
sometimes in the mail maybe even an
email whatever it is you don't got to
pick the first one credit karma can help
you zero in on the right option for you
and apply with more confidence sometimes
you get an offer and you think oh my god
i better just take this whatever you
don't have to do that credit karma is
here to help okay they use your credit
profile to show you the offers that are
tailored to your financial situation
credit karma partners with a wide range
of card issuers
so you can be sure that you're exploring
all sorts of options
and best of all credit karma uses your
credit data to show you your chances of
approval before you even apply
that's big and that's going to help you
apply with more confidence they're
comparing cards or you're comparing
cards rather on credit karma and it's
100
free won't affect your credit score
credit karma create your own karma so if
you're ready to find that card that's
perfect for you for you head to credit
karma and check out your personalized
mix of offers today go to
creditkarma.com or the credit karma app
and find the card for you that's
creditkarma.com
just understand too you have to
understand too whereas public school is
free right
public grade school is free and publicly
uh catholic grade school and high school
charges of tuition and then they also
collect money at their tax-free church
which needs to go towards buying the
pope more [ __ ] golden chalices for
the vatican a little bit better versus
giving the kids a decent environment to
learn
for the pope so anyway yeah it's it's
it's just it's a disgrace the way the
money in the church is used but my point
is is then they charge you for your
uniforms and they charge you for books
it's just so crazy anyway go ahead yeah
you're outdated books that you know
anyway it really started but but go
ahead with why the bagel bite is better
than the lunchable but yeah i would say
even remove school take after school if
you're at your house if you're you know
you're in eighth grade whatever you get
home parents are at work you got the
place to yourself yeah you pull open
that fridge and you gotta you got a box
of mini pizzas that cook perfectly
you're cooking up hot and fresh right
there yeah you do an oven are you doing
a microwave what are we dirt balls
hey i've
[Music]
it's a nice summer treat it's like it's
like a pizza pop these out by the pool
they're very refreshing
i like to put a few in my drink
um i had no patience to wait for the
oven as a kid i was a very fat kid too
so it was like if i can throw this in
there in three minutes and dude
it sucks now
but as a kid it might it seemed like a
hundred years but still
microwaves
you've yet to make the argument of why
it's superior than the lunchable why is
right off the bat
it's a soggy ass bagel bite it's it's
even when it's hot
that's your cooking skills i don't know
what to do no no no no
well it's the battle of substandard
ingredients we little greetings i think
that's grass-fed
i'll tell you this in a lunchable okay
cheese in the cheese department bagel
blade ain't [ __ ] with a lunchable
lunchable's cheese and the cracker alone
will carry you
much farther than
the back no but they had them they were
backed by oscar meyer weren't they yeah
they were
babe they're making
money
by the way sometimes some of the
lunchables came with a capri sun yeah
that's the news i'll give you that let
me ask you this
disgusting lunchables of course no
disgusting i mean a pepperoni a plane
is disgusting from front to back
ladies and
i was a gentlemen
he's an insane person here yeah but i'm
calling cops i liked him when i was a
kid when i had the ch when i had the
palate of a baby
he's like when i was
back at you i just think it's funny that
you said that yeah
we have them fighting in fighting
this is it let's go for a first round
knockout let's go with the lunchables
without drinks they run pepperoni and
mozzarella with crackers can you read
the first bad bagel bite that's what
that's a cold bagel but by the way
that's not mozzarella that's mozzarella
right yeah that's shitty mozzarella
that might as well be a craft stick yeah
can you see what it says at the small
print that i can't see your kids will
love your kids in every flavor-packed
bite
cheddar with crackers
it's for depressed people
it's for people who ran out of xanax
hammond switched with crackers one of
the greatest combinations that's not a
lunch throwing down the [ __ ] garlic
yeah yeah the the snack is itself not
them though no dude
you i'm telling you you take a you take
a lunchable cracker with a lunchable
piece of cheddar cheese and the ham you
have a better quality of meat
on the ground
you see one glass hut where does baby
now we're not even talking about this is
like the tv dinner
became a tv lunch you know what i'm
saying yeah sure this is like this is a
cold tv i disagree with that but it's
got it's got tv dinner
one of everything's got the cheese
cracker it's got the dessert in the
drink it's got a dessert a drink i i do
understand that's like ordering off the
menu
look at this one look at this one
they've got a bologna
light a light bologna good chocolate
chip
cookies come on dude i'll make my own
cookies you kidding me
who wants one oreo this is asinine
nobody wants one
everyone knows it's about portion
control
we should try that chicken pizza versus
a bagel bite here's the thing about the
bagel bites i hear the falafel
lunchables are really good
here's the thing about the bagel bite
okay everyone loves pizza but this is
really the least best pizza i understand
it's not the best it's not the highest i
do love it i think it's not pizza i
think it's a whole lot of pizza
ingredients on it
yeah it says it in the name cell they're
not lying to anybody the bagels too are
the lenders quality bagels now we're
from new york listen a bagel is serious
business
i'm not gonna sit here and let you
discredit the good people they didn't
hurt anybody you put them in the freezer
they come out of the toaster fresh
yeah but
you know what i'm talking about those
those they're really cardboardy the
bagel
they're not you know it's not uh like
brooklyn bagel or it's not it's not a
it's not a top topknot
the sauce is all right a lot of times
the sauce is not enough and the bagel
bite is a little dry okay
uh
dude you're gonna have a nice cold
you're dealing with substandard
ingredients at every level bad bagel bad
sauce well how's the hand in there
where do they where'd you get the where
it's not prosciutto here's my point
thanks
free range
here's my point here's my point with
lunchables you have a good cracker you
have a decent cheese because that cheese
doesn't have to be shredded and frozen
you're dealing with swiss here swiss
come on come on
shredded cheese that's got to last in
the freezer and then and then do the
thing in the oven it's a party any time
you mean cook
there's something they they're chemicals
you know you're all hanging out you're
you're out you're at a house party it's
it's two in the morning they're gonna
split a lunchable one year somebody goes
hey i got lunchables you're like get the
arrest this man or someone turns around
has a tray full of pizza bites okay fair
that's fair but that you're putting the
bagel bite in its environment then you
got to do that same with the lunch well
this place is the lunchable works that
the bagel bite doesn't if you don't sure
gas line
that's
oh get out of here damaged vapes i'll
give you that i'll give you that
sunscreen
every few minutes plus i don't like the
way i look
let's not get there
but dude he he's this is such a great
point if i'm
in in similar to the beach argument if
i'm stuck in a car on a long trip and i
got to stop at one of these gas station
marts on the way i have a two choices
lunchables or pizza bagels that i could
make in their microwave come on dude
lunchables yeah
wait remember when lunchables used to
have this is old school this they
stopped doing this remember when it had
the little thing of the g-shock
[Laughter]
a
do you remember when it had the little
thing of the mustard remember we had the
little thing of the dijon mustard that
that folded
it was the plastic and you squeezed it
oh come on dude this is a glorified
handy snack and it's not even as good as
a handy snack wow yeah what's a handy
snack come on the the four crackers with
the red stick and the cheese all right
the lunchables is trying to be yeah no
they're not on the steroids and they
miss no the thing that lunchables said
that's something we can improve on and
did oh i don't know what they did i mean
we even have lunchables these even has
google water lunchables suck
it's in the name too it's not a lunch
it's not a lunch it's a a lunch a bowl
yeah it's not a lunch it's not a lunch
if it was a lunch they'd be called
lunches let me tell you something
called lunch
breakfast market now they make breakfast
lunchables now do you know that oh no
nothing variety
i'm going to look at i'm looking at the
entire look at that look at this they
got cinnamon
that's an identity crisis that's what it
is the pizza bagel knows who they are oh
my god brushables
wow i bet you gotta heat those up though
and they're trying to figure it out like
they're doing a couple things right they
just i don't know it's like they're
poised for world nomination dinner is
the only meal left
this one's got a reese's peanut butter
cup and a capri sun in it i mean we're
doing they're now merging with one
reason peanut butter cup are you kidding
me yeah whatever
right this is only two people for a
reason pizza bagels
i'm gonna get theresa's cup on my own
that's fine i can have a reason about
knowing who you are joe
i mean you had 30 jobs at one mall are
you kidding me
you're the human version you're human
you're doing brunch you're doing the
bushes where are you at joe you got cold
pizza sauce on you yeah the whole thing
all right i like to look up at and say
like i could have turkey i could have
swiss i could have ham i could have
pizza i could have nachos i got a bagel
bite
how are you getting down how many are
you ready
oh that and then that just turns into
three slices of pizza that's the
equivalent you got a dinner you got a
lunch it's appetizing
listen hold on you put a couple bagel
bites on a silver plate at a party you
have enough dude you're the king you
might have
put a platter of bagel bites out of the
party that you were hosting i'd spit in
your face
i think you might have said otherwise on
this very podcast how dare you oh yeah
here we go here we go this guy's a
flip-flopper i think i saw joe's
stealing i think oscar meyer got the joe
that's what it is yeah oscar mayer got
to you what are they paying you joe
what's that i'm flying in right now
something smells good in here is that a
lunchable is that a lunch is that a hot
spot
no it's your precious [ __ ] i know it is
it smells delicious thanks
golden brown
for this get the drone look at that that
smells good okay see
what you
the bagel part of it is a dried little
hockey puck
has it figured out this is what you want
to see on pizza first of all sauce the
color of a blood
true orange you're eating cold lunch
meat slimy ham i mean listen and let's
pull this back a little bit when it's
supposed to be cold
i just got the warning
hold on pull this back they don't smell
bad
pull this
you get to the third action three's
company before they're ready
yeah i want to point out i want to point
out these were prepared by someone who
knows their way around a kitchen very
much this is not what a pizza is this is
not what a bagel bite looks like when
you make
hits i need something right away
lunchables all right
no
you know the team it's t-minus five
seconds before you get nourishment from
the lunchable listen 16 minutes all
right 16 minutes cooking including
how long's the preheat
that's a bite of pizza right now 24
minutes less commercials the whole
episode this was made
the best way you can make it
and it still tastes like [ __ ] oh you're
nuts it tastes like it tastes like it
was microwaved even though it wasn't
microwaved you're not it's terrible this
is fantastic yeah this is yours this is
insane you're lying to the face
[Music]
as good as chef boyardee
this is this is this is
this is this is bland
the texture of this it's fantastic you
got the bread
you're gonna sit here and honestly say
you're in eighth grade you show up at
your buddy's house okay
the mom says hey
we can either have pizza bagels or i'll
give you zitcha lunchable come on you
know be honest well oh sorry you're not
crazy like kim sal come over to the
other side yeah no but and that's i i
was illogical there are places that's a
bagel bite you're giving me scenarios
where i would agree sure would you like
the gas station with the lunchables
hold on a second that that doesn't we
agreed it was in its own space now both
of these are going to be argued in their
own space i'm not talking about being a
long-haul trucker or whatever you were
doing stuck in trouble i'll tell you
this right now i'll tell you this right
now if my friend's mom broke out bagel
bites like this without the pepperoni i
would have told her to take a hike right
now we're splitting hairs
i never did them for the longest let's
bring the lunchables
oh wait that's right
but you do have them in your freezer
even as a kid i wouldn't i only ate them
with the pepperoni even as a kid
but these are so good i'll allow it the
fans are chiming in they're saying that
the pizza bagels have a better slogan
like and what do we got pizza in the
morning
it's in the evening pizza
time when pizza is on a bagel you can
eat pizza anytime that's all we're doing
baby okay now let me point out why
that's a [ __ ] lyric yeah it doesn't make
any sense why because it's not a bagel
you can eat it i can eat regular pizza
anytime i i want you crazy bastard
and also they're rhyming time with time
it's a [ __ ] league also evening is
supper time so that's a pizza in the
morning pizza in the evening pizza at
suppertime they should have said pizza
in the morning and pizza in the
afternoon midnight or whatever yeah
sound crazy what do you want i don't
know
here's the thing now we're judging them
on their music
yeah
there's a crunch on the outside there's
a chewiness on the inside and it's it's
delicious yeah but you're going to get
it back you're going to get a crunch
with it with a with a slice of rice
and cheese yeah in the same way it's
lovely
here's the thing if you adjust the
ceiling of the bag
oh good dude right if you adjust the
ceiling of it then sure i i i can't
judge this against what it what it isn't
yes i understand what it is and that's
the whole point of the argument i guess
the bagel bite knows who they are
lunchables 90 different things they're
going to be making missiles in a couple
of weeks
get out of
and there's a big difference that's the
clip baby
for the record i am a [ __ ] we got to go
to the phones we got to go to the phones
uh this is where we read comments from
the fans okay okay lunchables are
charcuterie for the home great thank you
also just go get a turkey sandwich what
are we doing you want ham and cheese go
get a sandwich uh kelsey says both foods
both are kids foods but who doesn't look
at pizza lunchables with childhood
fondness
the kid who bought bread bagel
to school is almost certainly an adult
listen nobody
in high school i used to bring my
toaster in the morning and make waffles
oh this gets i'm sorry why did you go
and you're on you're on the side of
lunchables yeah i just
bring my toast to my two slices from
home in my backpack with with waffles
syrup and everything
matter
was this part of the show or something
no there was an outlet by our table and
i used to plug it in and make fresh
waffles
yeah no i didn't shimano okay
that's wild you weren't allowed to bring
a toaster together nobody said anything
i wasn't called no trouble it wasn't
homer
i ain't bothered no bunny huh
waffles the faker jake smith says the
fake ass meat they put into lunchables
was probably filled with enough micro
plastics to choke a horse thank you
ah bagel bites the single man's best
friend
lunchables bagel bites are disgusting in
the microwave so the oven is the only
choice if it takes me 15 minutes to
prepare something it should taste better
than a [ __ ] bagel bite thank you
lunchables like check fraud is for
children i don't understand that bagel
bites taste i understand that either i
don't know but i like it
taste like the soggy cardboard they are
packaged in under trash lunchables are
going to win on nostalgia alone but
aren't nearly as good as people remember
thank you they're not and i don't think
they were as popular as everybody
it was just the commercials nobody
really had them to be honest how many
lunchables have you really eaten in your
life dude i in my life i brought them to
school every day dude
it was college too they changed
us had never do that you probably had
one lunchable i'm just saying i didn't
bring lunchables
they were they were such a good bro you
brought a waffle maker
i kept them in the house for
after-school snacks when i was in high
school i loved those let's not say lunch
was gonna win on nostalgia because pizza
bagels are just as interesting
you can eat them in the morning in the
evening it's supper time too right here
but it's on a bagel you can eat them
that's a good point though they do
the bread the bagel does sometimes take
on a slight cardboard taste it does it
does it well yeah like
but both of these products are using
bottom of the barrel right but
a little bit better quality and bagel
bites carried with me an inherent frozen
flavor just like illios there's a
certain like a burnt yeah
that's because your mom wasn't sealing
them up right now you handle your
freezers right now that's not their
responsibilities taste free freeze what
are you talking about
on them i don't like saying mr derosa
has an okay point but it's an okay point
but i i'm
weird and a dirtball i like the freezer
burnt taste it reminds me of childhood
yeah all the stuff there's a lot of
stuff with freezer brands
let's read a couple more and then we got
to go to the vote before we go to the i
just want to say i'm going to eat this
last bagel bite
[Laughter]
hey they know their market
[Laughter]
for adults lunchables are for kids come
on i already know de rosa is on some
[ __ ] about how lunchables are fancy
i love when they think they know me they
don't know me you didn't say that
multiple times you said it was a high
quality cheese i just want to say one i
said it's a more quality cheese we're
talking about the ham the cheese the
turkey would have the cracker sure let's
talk about the other
huge
huge companies in there you got your
nestle crunch you got your capri sun
them in and of themselves they're their
own islands
but they have nothing to do with the
lunchables yeah they don't that's just
because
no we're not just
everything that's in that box is on the
table right if you're
if you're driving around in a 96 hyundai
with a million dollars in the back seat
you're still driving around in a hyundai
no no no no because it doesn't matter
the strength of the lunchables coming
from
i bought the hyundai with 100 100
million in it or whatever you said so
you're telling everything that's in that
box is part of the lunchable done you're
so you're telling me the best part about
a lunchable is something that you're not
responsible for that's exactly what you
just said count
it does there is some accoutrements
right okay let's give the win and it's
not an unidentified juice
it's true it's a capri sun sure and it's
not some generic chocolate yeah it's a
nestle i agree okay let's give the win
to the in-cell comment i think it's the
funniest pimp that's our winner
get them to follow uh where is it adult
in cell with all then so i thought it so
well while he's doing that and before we
go to the winner let's we didn't even
properly we said who you're doing do we
injure did you guys want to just do any
players kevin ryan and a trolley from ru
garbage uh check out our podcast both of
you both of you have done it um their
podcast is the most fun podcast i think
i've ever done yeah i want to do it
again you should check it out it's every
single episode you see how funny these
guys are every single episode is laugh
out loud funny it is true it's one of
the only pods i look forward to doing
like when i when i've done it i'm not
like [ __ ] yeah like it's a chore i
appreciate a lot of podcasts you're like
once you're there you're having fun but
beforehand you're like why the [ __ ] did
i say i would do this i got your deck
we're all over the road uh we do a live
show we each go headline and then we
play ayg with the crowd a little bit
it's a good time it's wild it's a lot of
fun uh we're all over the road we're in
jersey uh nashville portland seattle
kansas city providence boston yeah all
over we're cooking great check it out
i'm not gonna try to say it
l-u-c-a-b-i-s-c-e-g-l-i-a
[Music]
for the winning tweet today the kid who
brought bagel bites to school is almost
certainly an adult in cell and pimp here
we go oh before you go
do us a favor if you want to support the
pod in a very easy way you go and you
follow the no press channel on youtube
you leave a a review on itunes if you
can or follow us on spotify that's a
huge help to us and that's so if you
like the podcast please go ahead and do
that also a quick note on that i love
the fact that you guys did that the no
press network the name of it
everything's awesome it's just so cool
it's awesome
that's awesome there's a comedy show in
austin now called no presh oh yeah um
from our attention mike i don't want to
break balls it's an open mind please
give me five minutes that's all i have
but i was a little like come on guys
sure anyway um okay so this is how we do
it we get we take the vote we announce
who won to this this is the humble boss
a lot of people vote somebody's going to
eat humble party how would we got on
that what do we got
it's almost 7 000.
says to the loser i still love you and
you say i love you back and then we're
done okay all right all right the winner
says i still love you you're the loser
the winner says i love you and then i
still love you yeah yeah seven we
usually have 15 20 000 but i don't know
why i think i did it too late here we go
pimp's going lunchables this is
[Laughter]
this was very close and so this ended up
this ended up being an excellent battle
we put together when it's that close you
know it's a really good battle yeah uh
it's it's available by its guys i gotta
be honest with you i thought we were
gonna lose i did really much about the
reason
of it is huge i thought
55.3 bagel bites guys and we took 44 7.7
for lunchables that's that's a that's a
very very well earned win and i still
love both of you we love you love you
both thank you so much for joining this
is so much fun taste buds they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds